paradoxalement en apparence certains
artistes ont demandé aujourd'hui que le
mur ne soit pas complètement détruit et
puisqu'il était devenu au fil de ses 28
années douloureuses ici ou là une oeuvre
d'art en soi pas surprenant lorsqu'on se
rappelle que berlin a toujours été
culturellement parlant à l'avant garde
et le mur a inspiré à quantité
d'artistes et quelques chefs-d'oeuvre
berne à briançon dans cette ville où
l'histoire est physiquement présente
l'image d'une ville de culture
d'avant-garde n'est pas usurpée ce n'est
d'ailleurs pas un hasard si à berlin
ville moribonde qui porte cette
cicatrice depuis 28 ans et où tout est
apparemment cris et triste froid et
inhumain qu'on y trouve les traces des
mouvements les plus iconoclastes et les
plus contestataires s'ils ont également
le nombre d'artistes écrivains peintres
musiciens cinéastes qui ont essayé de
maintenir le dynamisme de cette ville on
est frappé de voir que ce sont pour la
plupart ce qu'on pourrait appeler des
marginaux dans cette ville où l'absence
d'avenir le no future fille un lieu
idéal
selander grande qui fait la réputation
de berlin
certaines point de vue malin ça no man's
land sans vie de sa cruelle et dans ce
creux des gens du monde entier se sont
rencontrés ne paie pas mal de temps ils
sont restés là justement parce que ça
leur convient ce creux un peu absurde
représente balla le ciel au dessus de
berlin justement film de wim wenders ou
les ailes du désir décrit une certaine
idée de la ville deux ans ce sont les
héros de ce film est justement ce statut
dans jeu leur permet de se faire la
belle en pays communiste pour un artiste
aujourd'hui je vois pas mes avis la
demande surtout pas pour le peintre et à
la toile la plus grande et elle est
gratuite
il a raté les murs on peut aller peindre
les jours et on apprend des années on ne
peut pas s'étonner alors que beaucoup
d'artistes se soit intéressé à berlin ou
en effet le prétexte facile de leur
déambulation histoire de se dire de
montrer qu'on est aussi à la mode
berlin est une ville schizophrène non
seulement à cause de sa coupure est
ouest mais aussi à cause de cet autre
coupure moins visibles les artistes et
le reste de la population
alors qu'un rôle a trouvé un chez soi à
dallas c'est très facile et très vivable
justement à cause de son statut
impossible est absurde spécificité
berlinoise la musique dur obsédante
répétitives musique lite alternatives
dont le prototype et le groupe
einstürzende neubauten traduction
littérale et nouveaux immeubles en voie
de disparition
un nom prémonitoire leurs instruments
musique marteaux scies et hc lire si
l'obsession de la démolition alimente
les esprits les plus entreprenants ils
vont pouvoir aujourd'hui s'en donner à
coeur joie